OK, so now we have an idea for a
different algorithm,
and it's going to be based off of an
approach called “branch and bound”.
So let's learn a little bit about this and
I'm going to give a
really hazy, vague overview of what a
branch and bound algorithm's idea is.
So, you're going to start with a
simple candidate solution and you're going
to “expand” it
or “branch” that out into different
solutions, and then you might do this
again.
Then, after you've branched out into a
number
of possible solutions, or small seeds of
larger possible solutions,
then you're going to say, OK, can we
exclude any of those?
Can we eliminate any of these candidate
solutions that we have?
And that's called the “bound step”.
So from here to here we've eliminated
five solutions, and we're left with, these
are
not necessarily solutions, but they're at
least candidates
for solutions, at the leaves of this tree.
Then we say, okay let's branch again, and
then we'll need to bound.
Based off of some condition, we'll exclude some of
these
edges when we move from branch to bound.
And now we have, maybe some candidate
solutions,
and we can go ahead and test these.
So we've found a way of
eliminating certain solutions, before we
construct them.
So we want to apply the same idea to
eliminating
some candidate peptides, before they ever
get generated.
Let's apply it to cyclopeptide
sequencing, then.
Here's a possible spectrum.
And our first question is,
which amino acids have masses in the
spectrum?
So if we bring back this integer
mass table, then we highlight, P has mass 97,
and it occurs in the Spectrum, V has
mass 99, it occurs in the Spectrum.
We also get T and C.
So we're going to start with four 1-mer
peptides.
We're going to start with just these
single amino acids, and what we're going to
do is, we're going to extend these four
into all possible 2-mer peptides,
all possible amino acid strings of
length 2. So we get PA, VA, TA, and CA.
We get PC, VC, TC, and CC, and so on.
So, we started with four, and we're going
to
now multiply that by 18, because we're
adding each possible amino acid
onto each of these four and we're
left with 72.
So, we want to know how we can trim this
list.
So we've done our branch step, and now we need
to do our bound step and bring it
back.
To do this trimming, we'll notice
that PV is what's called “consistent” with
Spectrum.
Here's one possible 2-mer, and
you'll notice that the mass of P is equal
to 97, it’s present.
The mass of V, the other
letter in PV,
is present as 99, and the mass of
this
entire small linear peptide, PV, is 196,
and its also detected.
So that's called “consistent”, if when
you chop up this candidate solution, and
weigh its fragments, that all those
fragments are found in the spectrum.
CD is one that we actually created, in
the expand step, but it's inconsistent
with this spectrum.
So although 103, the mass of C, is present,
is detected, 115 and 218,
the mass of D and the mass of the entire
2-mer peptide CD, they're not found.
You can't find 115 or 218 in this
spectrum. So we want to exclude CD.
After we do this step, and
we figure out what it is that we need to trim
we're left with ten amino acid
strings of length two.
From our 72, we've cut it down to ten.
So let's do this exact same thing.
Let's expand each of these in all 18
possible directions.
We'll get now, 180 different 3-mer
peptides, and then let's check
whether or not each one is consistent, and
we'll trim it down.
After we do this,
we go from 180 to 15, and we say, OK, this
is going well, we're preventing these
peptides from growing crazily.
So we expand them, and then we'll
trim.
We go from 15 and do 15 times 18 to get 270.
And then we find which of those 270 4-mers
are consistent with the spectrum, and
we're down to ten.
And we do it one more time,
expand and then trim, and we're left with
ten consistent 5-mers.
And you can verify that
each of these
corresponds to the exact same cyclic
peptide,
and the spectrum of this
cyclic peptide coincides exactly with our
experimental spectrum.
So now we have a method that's going to
work
and it looks like it's going to be pretty
efficient.
I'll just summarize what it is.
We find all the amino acids whose masses
occur
in the spectrum, and we add them to a list.
Then we extend every peptide that's
currently in the list in every possible
direction.
So we add each of 18 different amino acid
masses, onto the end of it, and then we
have
this trim step, where we say, let's take
which of
these are inconsistent and let's just get
rid of them.
Then we'll return any peptides whose
theoretical
spectra match the experimental spectrum
that we're given.
And we'll do steps 2 through 4 over
and over again, this branching and bounding
and then testing, until we run out of
peptides to consider, until we have all
inconsistent peptides.
We've seen it works really well on an example,
but we ask ourselves whether or not this
algorithm is efficient in practice?
The brute force algorithm that we saw
before, it was exponential, and by
“exponential” I mean, if you look at its
input size, the number of steps
that it has to take or, in
this case, the number
of peptides that it has to consider,
grows exponentially with respect to the
input size.
It may be true that the branch and bound
algorithm
that we've come up with is exponential on
some dataset.
Like, somewhere way out in the galaxy you
can form some dataset that takes a
really, really long time to run and is prohibitive.
But in practice, it's
actually really fast.
So, it looks like we're done and, we can
have a party and go home.
That's the question though:
can we really?
And I'm going to have to pop that balloon
and say “no”.